let me tell you something Shelly sunny I
need to tell you something first
let me tell you a little something I
want to tell you something I can tell
you for a fact the guy is full of [ __ ]
you've got a big mouth and now I'm gonna
show you an even bigger one try to
follow me because I'm gonna be moving in
a kind of circular motion so if you pay
attention there will be a point you have
no brain I don't like you he's an idiot
you are a goddamn [ __ ] liar from
the word go are you trying to get a rise
out of me
shut up listen learn see your finger at
my hands Alan will let me make this
clear for you okay
it's just aa couch reality maybe it's
reality that I clubs a reality it's not
like the freaking movies that are all
goddamn fake I don't think the yelling
is misses him I'm sorry did I did I hurt
your feelings the greatest trick the
devil ever pulled was convincing the
world he didn't exist
oh yeah everybody wonders about God
every now and then some of us don't
dwell on it you know I don't believe in
God but I'm afraid of him unless you
take the things that you don't like
about this world and you flip them
upside down we're not here to save souls
what excuse me what I'm sorry what I'm
sorry you want something from me so what
do you want from me what do you do do
you know me is that supposed to be funny
people say I talk too much that's why
there's hope Bob because there's people
like me who listen I rule